mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur und
swisslos wünschen ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
das sich auf den nächsten sieg sagt dass
er nicht doch machen sie schon ganz
schön schwierig so eine
vater-tochter-beziehung was dieser so
besonders macht jetzt bei kulturplatz
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei kulturplatz wir
sind heute in thundorf beim waldhof wo
eine tochter jede freie minute verbringt
und ein vater sich nach immerhin alle
mühe gibt könne englisch bacher mit
seiner tochter laura in unser
schwerpunkt heute sind väter und töchter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
1986 schaffte grüne rindlisbacher
zusammen mit stefan schmid ihn als
comedy duos mir ins kies den durchbruch
[Gelächter]
weiter ging's ab 1995 mit der
samstagabend sendung top of switzerland
die ein millionenpublikum erreichte
dafür gab es den prix walo in immer neue
rollen schlüpfte rené rindlisbacher mit
seinem bühnenpartner sven vorher als duo
edelmais brachten sie auf tournee und im
fernsehen das publikum zum lachen dass
man sich gut und gern um circa 40 uhr
rollt beachten sie werden sich revier
markiert und war somit sicherer hand
macht ergriff konto oder haben will.i.am
otto im laufe der evolution immer eine
region zur gleichheit und darum in die
hand gaben
das ist das spießige hängebauchschwein
was hat das casino unterbezirk man sonst
im casino als automat seit zwei jahren
steht der familienvater nun mit tochter
laura auf der bühne programm ist comedy
programm oh nein papa 8
es ist wirklich ziemlich stolz teenager
keine vorstelle mit ihm mit ihm vor
thomas schaaf versorgen
nein nein wahrscheinlich nötig so viel
theater gespielt für mich aber ich werde
nicht durch die dqs im bereich comedy
pro sekunde anzuschließen schauspieler
auf der bühne aber mit ihm zusammen sind
also weit man das zeit damals schon
endlos effektiv ich operiert nachdem
mailbox
was mache ich jetzt intern und in europa
aber du bist nicht los
sie schrammte eigentlich nicht und darum
sehen wir fragen schafft intensiv und
darum auch danach eine familiäre umso
mehr für geschäftlich aber nicht immer
ganz aufgehört ich mich natürlich sehr
erfahrene fischer lehrmeister was kommt
trifft frau schuldig abgrenzen ihre
rolle
ja weil ich weiß ja dass er meistens
hast du das sagen manche nacht hat die
idee was er mir sein abgrenzen
ja mir sind es sei mir hey das und das
war gut für bühne und das war gut für
die situation und ich mache eigentlich
ich weiß dass afrikaner sehr viel
erfahrung hat und dann würde ich eine
textanzeige den heimlichen hinterfrage
auf jeden fall also es gibt sicher
situationen auf der bühne der bühne
momentan findet des boss militzer sonst
bin ich jetzt nicht so lässig wie wäre
es mit dem und den reden wir darüber
das leben als tochter ist kein ponyhof
das als vater auch nicht jedenfalls
nicht immer die bandbreite der
vaterrolle die reicht vom erzeuger über
den ernährer bis hin zur wichtigsten
emotionalen bezugspersonen wie sehr
väter die entwicklung ihrer töchter
beeinflussen ein leben lang das erörtern
zwei neue bücher ein vater weist der
tochter den weg in die welt
kann beschützen bestärken und ermutigen
er kann aber auch entwerten beschädigen
und zerstören diese spannbreite der
beziehung lotet die schweizer autorin
susanne sitzler in ihrem neuen buch
väter und töchter aus zitierte bei ihre
eigene vater beziehung ergänzt durch
gespräche mit vätern und töchtern und
erkenntnisse aus väter forschung und
psychologie zu ihrem vater hatte sitzler
ein spannungsvolles verhältnis das
gefälle war groß sie distanzierte sich
von ihm nicht nur persönlich bei mir
sondern sich in vielen beziehungen
zwischen fahrplan tochter dass es
einfacher maximale asymmetrie enthalten
also wenn man von der archetypische
rolle oder seine autorität in der
gesellschaft ist eine totale gegenteil
vom nach wien meidling in traditionellen
familien hielten die väter oft distanz
waren für die starke hand und schulter
verantwortlich die mütter für die gefüge
für trost und anerkennung
doch die rolle des pater familias hat
sich in den letzten jahrzehnten
gewandelt
mein vater ist heute auch verbündeter
sparringpartner und sympathischer fahrer
oft wollen es die männer zu sitzler
anders machen als ihre eigenen väter der
film sind hört also gerade junge vater
seiner durch viel lieber im internet
internet im alltag die man gar nicht auf
dem sockel steht eben lieber auf
augenhöhe ist sie
[Musik]
ihrem eigenen vater auf augenhöhe
begegnen das konnte susan sitzler erst
nach seinem tod durch die arbeit an
ihrem buch
[Musik]
sie löste sich von idealisierung mit dem
sie seinem leben nachforschte was dort
gesicht würde ich sagen es lohnt sich
unbedingt sie vater als erwachsener
mensch canons lehrer also nicht nur was
ist für mehr als vater sein was ich dass
ein mensch was sonst nur so in sinnloser
sie vater sie in einem neuen fotobuch
erzählt die deutsche fotografin bettina
flitner wie väter ihre töchter stärken
können für ein selbstbestimmtes leben
darin geht es ausschließlich um positive
beziehung also ich habe mir ja die väter
rausgesucht die eben unterstützend sind
und die fördern sind und bei dieser art
von vätern ist es eben so dass sie ihre
töchter ernst nehmen dass sie sagen kann
du kannst alles machen
lauf los hab keine angst ich trau dir
alles zu mache einfach die fotografin
hat 18 vater tochter gespann gefunden
die sich gleichberechtigt begegnen
einander unterstützen und aneinander
wachsen
darunter wissenschaftsjournalist ranga
yogeshwar der seinen drei töchtern
selbstvertrauen wissensdurst und
angstfreiheit mit gibt sie danken es ihm
mit nähe und humor
die edleren im berner oberland folgt
ihrem vater nach und will statt ihrer
brüder den hof übernehmen er ein
männerberuf für den vater kein problem
macht einen einen guten vater aus der
eben ja der nicht festgefahren ist in
seinen bildern und vorstellungen wie
eine frau werden muss oder wie ein mann
werden väter und töchter die bücher
schärfen den blick dafür wie diese
bindung zu einer glücklichen prägung
fürs leben werden kann und sie regen
dazu an über die eigene familie
nachzudenken
[Musik]
ich habe normal
ich hoffe - also die anderen familien
ist der ganze scheiß ist immer am
vormittag und aufwuchs hat sich so hin
und her gut sind die forderung laut das
ja jetzt auf die klinik standort genannt
wie hat das eure 40 freunde neben also
es ist nach wie vor genau die hand
miranda im bild der familie das ist für
uns ganz wichtig sie sind also die
habilitation da ein gewisser früher war
es passiert ist mit mir
frank hat es sich um vermeintlich bisky
wer wo man eine pause machen was auch
immer und das habe ich mit ihnen
besprochen
das paar stand mehr oder weniger und
muss manchmal heute noch an some twenty
four ist musst du es gibt also wirklich
das ist ja weißt du nie das ist ja viel
mit endo ist das natürlich jetzt viel
mehr damit die ganze familie dem jahr
forum lockt dann haben wir die ganze
familie immer die periode bis mo mi im
verlies sind erkannte unterstützt und
cool und zu sehen natürlich auch als
gesamt familie zusammengewachsen wie du
halt wirklich jeder situation sich und
erlaubt so und ich glaube es wäre
einfach langsam muslime und sprach damit
sprach langsam das innen- und und jetzt
macht es spaß wenn ich einmal ja wenn
ich merke ich hoffe ich ein guter oder
so es macht immer mehr spaß und ich
glaube so inhalt das verbinden dass man
als familie mit zittern da brauch dass
man wirklich auch geschäftlich unterwegs
sind und die diskussionen handeln oder
verschweigt die schranke gesprochen das
weiß man dass christus gemacht was hat
das mit ihr gemacht leider als
ramponiert das bild vom staat will ich
finde das macht dann nur noch stärker
als jetzt gab ihm halt das halt noch
stärker gemacht und wo es als familie
mit mir sind so oft waren das immer mit
salat für uns ist es auch sehe ich meine
es gibt noch viel schlimmere sachen
erlebt und so aber für uns ist klar dass
familien schlink sie zum teil und sie
später mit mehr schlimmer für mich als
dann aus dem ganzen gemacht wurden ist
immer an der christ jetzt gott zum gut
oder wie er immer und ich eine gewisse
mir stärker ist dass ich gerne wieder
zurück zu herrn schumacher gemacht der
schrift x oder ein comedy du hast deinen
eigenen weg gemacht mit der wirtschafts-
natur- dann also die stadt geschafft ist
das für dich damals schwierig die lehrer
[Musik]
haben zwar lange gewusst was sie will
er stand ja vielleicht studiere ich das
was ich will mache aber handeln dass der
beste weg für mich entdeckt wird mit der
wirtschaftsmittelschule quasi man hat
ein großer praktische teil drin und hat
viel mit sprache und mit mit der
schaufel natur aber natürlich auch von
den schulklassen und ich nicht so viele
jobs es ist also teils teils
das haben wir das in der regel roter
gerd vom vater das ist ja was machen wir
in bregenz den cl sehr streber und 12
sind halt mädels und drehbuchschreiber
haben die lehrer oder gimme diese frage
ist gerade eine besonders
herausfordernde denn jugendliche die
sich im dschungel der möglichkeiten
orientieren müssten die haben es
bekanntlich auch noch mit einer pandemie
zu tun bekommt und die wirst ganz neue
fragen auf französisch unterricht in der
sekundarschule bassersdorf im kanton
zürich
in diesem jahr müssen die schüler der
zweiten klasse die eine lehrstelle
finden
im teil shutdown der arbeitswelt eine
berufswahl zu treffen ist nicht ganz
einfach
und dann bin ich raus metzgerin also ein
netz gegangen
und es ist schwierig sitzungswoche will
alle halter zeier corona mit
kundenkontakt ist
50 50 20 e mails geschrieben und sehr
viel ab und bald mit moskau gegangen
sind und es ist schwierig sie eine
passende schnupperlehre in diesem jungen
alter zu finden ist eine herausforderung
doch die pandemie erschwert den
berufseinstieg noch zusätzlich welchen
einfluss hat die krise auf die
berufswahl pro woche - handwerklichen
musiker und die hand bekam kein problem
mit struktur lehre finden das gibt es
aber die anderen lehrling ist jetzt mal
vor allem die gerufen wenn der büro
textur büro im kopfbereich lehrstelle
suchen die anzahl schwieriger außerdem
ist es dort sachliche so dass die
natürlich schafft der hand die
angestellten im home office oder im
homeoffice verschnupft die schweiz mit
ihrem dualen bildungssystem auf der
einen seite die berufsbildung mit lehre
und berufsschule auf der anderen die
allgemeine schulbildung mit gymnasium
und uni wäre es in einer
wirtschaftlichen krise nicht sinnvoll
die berufsbildung zurückzufahren und
dafür den zutritt zur allgemeinen
schulbildung zu erleichtern
wir fragen den bildungsforscher stefan
wolter frage wo sieht die jahre ständig
ufo ist unabhängig von der krise und sie
ist jetzt ein speziell an das wort krise
es ist natürlich so dass brust belegte
nachteil hat das weltwirtschafts
schlacht läuft keine lehrstelle an bord
würdet dann hat das muss wird geprüft ob
der jugendliche chance hat die
ausbildung können zu machen
wenn es allgemein bildende systemen
können die an und für sich so viel
ausbildungsplatz anbieter wie einfach
notwendig wäre und sie wird aber
natürlich das problem einfach
zieht nachahmer also gib deinen machen
gymnasium nach der uni genügend stelle
ohne sind das verhältnis zwischen anzahl
lehrstellen und zulassungsquote fürs
gymnasium ist kantonal sehr
unterschiedlich der aargau hat eine
tiefe zulassungsquote fürs kino
es braucht zwar keine prüfung aber man
muss einen notenschnitt von 4,7
erreichen bei einfluss die pandemie die
bestrebungen der schüler weniger wo der
47 mit hunter serie wird sich
wahrscheinlich zumal die band hoffe dass
sich oft völlig der praxis tätigen ohne
lehrstelle suchen
das ist oft faulen es ist nicht einfach
auch in anderen kantonen sind die
anmeldungen fürs gymnasium leicht
angestiegen
seit die pandemie gewisse
wirtschaftszweige lahmgelegt hat wäre
das der moment den zugang an die
kantonsschulen zu erleichtern will
endlich nun auch vielleicht nur acht die
tradition und das ist dann schon vor ich
weiß nicht was das ist das projekt wurde
jegliche versuche bio ist der übertritt
bereits noch der zweite zu ermöglichen
wie das in vielen kantonen oder zweitens
nicht da wirklich die drei folgejahre
die oberstufe und grillt er stochert er
ist im tessin und in der romandie
hingegen hat die berufslehre einen
schweren stand
dafür sind die zulassungsquote fürs
gymnasium um einiges höher mit negativen
konsequenzen vermehrt schaffen schüler
entweder gymnasium oder
universitätsabschluss nicht mehr brauche
gymnasium braucht universitäten brauchen
berufsbildung und rathaus in einem
gesunden verhältnis und das
kundenverhalten ist das kann man nicht
auf dem reißbrett ausrechnet das wird
sich aber anderen über überzieht aber
muss einfach nur das manuskript
falsche verhältnis und das heißt
jugendliche plus billig zwingen oder mit
berufsbildung überlebt aber man wisse
dass wir bloß bildungshunger dass sie
dann auch für die brust billiger gute
ausbildung ist gut ins bild ich mir
während die pandemie hat gezeigt es ist
zwar schwer eine gute schnupperlehre zu
finden
doch die lehrstellen sind nicht
weggebrochen das duale bildungssystem
scheint der krise erfolgreich zu trotzen
[Musik]
der druck auf die jungen ist hoch und es
beginnt oft schon in der sechsten klasse
beim übertritt zur oberstufe eine
berührende auseinandersetzung mit dieser
ersten weichenstellung zeigt doch im
film mein leben und der notenschnitt
morgen auf sf1 um 20 uhr 5 oder bereits
jetzt im netz einmal lässt ich
entscheide gehen
ich mache alles ist so wie tut sich aber
auf der hand
das ist gruselig dass ich das probiere
ich muss
[Musik]
nicht in die fußstapfen des papas
sondern in jene eines musikalischen über
vaters tritt der schweizer andreas reize
er wird der 18
nachfolger von johann sebastian bach als
leiter des weltberühmten leipziger
thomanerchores ab september ist er damit
als thomaskantor auch so eine art
vaterfigur für rund 100 sänger im
teenager-alter mitreißen
das kann er eine barockoper sei es von
rameau zum ersten mal auf einer bühne in
der schweiz so was liebt andreas reize
doch seine große leidenschaft sind chöre
wie hier der zürcher bach chor den er
seit zehn jahren leitet
doch er ist bereit zum absprung aus der
schweiz
dorthin wo chorgesang kultur erbe ist
nach leipzig zum berühmten thomanerchor
ab september wird er als thomaskantor
übernehmen ganz dem erbe bachs
verpflichtet
[Musik]
jeder kann tor ist hier auch bach
nachfolger
der meister war der berühmteste
chorleiter der thomaner komponierte
hunderte von kantaten für sie andreas
reize aus solothurn ist der achtzehnte
nach dem meister bachs musik ist nahrung
seit er denken kann ansporn erdung
ich danke besser atmen sie dabei haben
unglaublich so fordert es gibt das
gebracht wo ein unglaublicher grenze
bringen
ein hamas mit spielen musik alisch und
technisch dermaßen gut machen
das scheitere frau schmidt ich
komponiert was möglich sei unglaublich
intensiv damit auseinandersetzen
[Musik]
mit den thomanern kein problem
traditionell studiert der knabenchor
jede woche ein neues werk von bach ein
alles im leben der jungen sänger ist
dafür eingerichtet fast wie bei
hochleistungssportlern wohnort die jungs
das heißt dass er jeden tag dass thomas
kontrollmöglichkeit mit der jugend jede
probe
das geht eher intensität wo immer eine
rolle der schweiz oder augen eine
lebenszeichen aber auch in deutschland
so gar nicht möglich ist wenn wir
zweimal pro woche sieht in der schweiz
leiter 13 einen der traditionsreichsten
chöre die singknaben der st ursen
kathedrale solotour natürlich gab es
während der pandemie höchstens
reduzierte proben kaum auftritte
ausgerechnet jetzt muss er sich
verabschieden von seinem chor mit dem
ihn viel verbunden hat die jungs haben
gut getan hatte mitte juni unter nach
dem mini und jugend bietet gesungen und
für mich immer klar ob sie das ist das
ganze am montag ganz spezielle service
auf zeit muss man sich einfach sehr
reizvoll und hat es immer wieder
[Musik]
seit über 800 jahren bilden die thomaner
ihre ganz besondere gemeinschaft der
große stolz der stadt leipzig bis heute
ist eine ausbildung auf diesem campus
keine frage des geldes
die stadt finanziert die erstklassige
musikalische bildung
es ist ein alt bewährtes system das auch
darauf beruht dass die älteren den
jüngeren helfen
ich denke dass das ein ganz große
tradition einfachheit und danke große
angst sind da übernachtet die angst dass
die tradition wird auf einem rendite co
muss ich aber sagen wie sehr eine
tradition auch selber aufgewachsen ist
und findet bisher schönsten inseln handy
auch in ganz langen tradition und ich
finde es eine bewahre und doch august
ist richtig öffentlich zu das muss eine
widersprach verbraucht für das
auswahlkomitee in leipzig bringt andreas
reize alles mit was ein thomaskantor
braucht talent visionen erfahrung
doch ältere thomaner probten den
aufstand brachten einen eigenen
kandidaten ins spiel
der neue aus der schweiz der katholik
musste schon viel aufregung ertragen
der sturm hat sich gelegt
[Musik]
mich hat sich die sache anders gewünscht
will ich jetzt sehr viel wirbel gab
und dort sieht er in ruhe bringen auch
an die awards wo das sicher nicht ganz
einfach
an ihm soll es nicht lieben und das
einpacken hat begonnen
bachs nachfolger ist gut organisiert und
sortiert schon orchester noten das
allerheiligste für einen dirigenten
und dahinter ja da ist dass ich das wohl
innerhalb des natürlich täglich brot ist
schwarzbrot in leipzig ist natürlich an
sebastian bach da aber jetzt mal ab hört
sich für die matthäus passion die 102
mio und so viel material in der schweiz
müssen chöre und publikum nun ohne
andreas reize auskommen
der abschied schwungvoll und reichhaltig
die rameau oper in solothurn und b so
ein thomaskantor ist eben ein musiker
der zu begeistern weiß
zu machen
[Musik]
das war es von uns für heute nächste
woche ist mein kulturplatz gleich
zweimal einmal mit dem gleichnamigen
künstlerkollektiv und seinem super 7
widerstand und einmal mit einem
unerhörten musikerlebnis mit den neuen
orchester basel es knallt also nächste
woche mit eva wannenmacher und tier geht
es jetzt weiter mit der zweiten staffel
von die wege des herrn und ich gehe
wieder seiner wege gestanden
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]